since the dawn of our species we have  looked to the Stars with wonder now we  travel among them exploring expanding  now we face new questions what kind of  civilization will we become how will we  grow it how will we deal with those who  claim the Stars for themselves  and those who will take them by any  means necessary this is your story the  story of your galactic civilization one  that researches wondrous new  technologies trades with alien  civilizations employs spies and  saboteurs spreads its culture across the  known galaxy you will assemble the best  and brightest your civilization has to  offer  gather allies and defeat those who would  stand against you and if necessary  prevent them from ever taking to the  stars  [Music]  you